Posey welcome to you you are the third
largest party now at Westminster what is
the status of meetings with the
government is there something that's
actually been fixed I don't think it's
fixed yet but they'll have to be
Scottish to UK government meeting sir
Nick was a signal that has to happen and
I think it would be helpful for happen
as quickly as possible I mean she of
course was here today but I might you
she's not an MP it's that going to be
difficult i mean just organizationally
because no you you will have to take
decisions down here without be able to
refer back to it oh absolutely you Angus
Robertson is a group leader down here
incredibly experienced I'm the deputy
leader of both fit party and the
Westminster group the contact and
liaison is fantastic so know that winter
that would offer any hindrance at all
what does it mean being the third
largest part that means a number of
things there are rights and
responsibilities so for example places
on select committees collects the
chairmanship of committees the ability
to pull ministers to account with
questions every departmental question
called earlier and statements and Arjun
questions the whole range of ways in
which part is called the government
account unknown place and out i mean
participating every week care probably
in premises questions absolutely right a
few questions every week and we expect
and that that makes a big difference as
well in terms of the key issues of the
day our position we made clear and the
proper questions been filtered by now
you obviously an old hand says Angus
Robertson your leader here says Alex
Salmond and a number of your MPs but the
majority of them are real new comes to
this except they bring huge experience
people from finance people vote for the
World Bank consultant oncologist an
international QC there's huge experience
in that group and I'm struggling to see
a weak link at all which I'm not saying
I'm not saying they're not qualified
people but but you know Parliament is
still Parliament and I just wonder when
they said well we're going to come here
and we're going to stop austerity and
we're going to make the voice of
Scotland be heard whether they're in for
a nasty shock in the sense that you know
you are only 55 out of 650 MP suppose of
one was being cynical you could see that
the same
limitations apply to every single MP
every party except for the three or four
at the very heart of government but as
you know government's do listen they're
forced to listen and I think this
government have a particular problem in
relation to the SNP 56 out of 59 MPs
half the vort a very clear mandate
indeed to speak up on behalf of the
people scrolls for the policies in our
manifest as organized you can you gotta
split you got a right to speak out it's
a question whether you can make any diff
for think the government this Tory
government would be foolish if they were
to brush this away and think it was mere
Bagatelle that there's nothing we can do
technically therefore they wouldn't
respond i think that would be tactically
and strategically very very foolish
David Cameron do you think it would be a
good idea as Lord Lawson was just saying
to me to have a convention about looking
again the powers within the UK obviously
the SP has an ultimate different name
but for now you know there is merit in
that because clearly there has to be
some form of recognition and evolution
for or to England clearly in Wales as a
demand for more powers and so on and so
forth but that cannot be allowed to stop
further powers coming to Scotland and
that is pie Wars north of the Smith
Commission which will water down before
the election and are frankly very modest
and not adequate to do the job we need I
mean the key one is obviously this one a
fiscal autonomy is that something that
you would like in short order well in
short order that's difficult because
it's complicated and there would be a
lead time to deliver that so what we've
said is yes we want that but in the
meanwhile we need the powers to grow the
economy create jobs and make society
feral business tax is welfare there's a
package which we pick together in terms
of priorities in the manifesto there's
no reason why that cannot be devolved
while the other stuff is in process and
perhaps a convention looking at Power
Stone the UK starts work and what are
you hearing back from what is now the
conservative majority government about
those well we've only been here for kind
of six hours yeah let's get the new
members inducted the swearing in next
week we have the Queen's Speech the
following week at that point I think
we'll begin to crystallize are they
prepared to play ball and understand the
new reality or is it going to be
business as usual from their point of
view which I suspect will be met with
huge resistance for our new members me
is there is the ultimate threat that
said he said if you don't feel you're
being listened to you could procedurally
stuff up Parliament what you know we all
know there are ways to meet life comp a
complicated difficult for a government
with a very small majority but we're not
here to be disruptive what we're seeing
is we have a substantial mandate what we
asked for in the manifesto which the
public in Scotland voted for was very
clear so let's get a good positive
response from the government and see if
we can't move forward in a sensible way
if they decide to say no enough's enough
no more powers then of course we look at
all the tactics any opposition party
they can deploy as you thank you very
much thank you